et notre invité politique pour cette
émission spéciale depuis bourg-en-bresse
où se tient donc ce congrès des
départements c'est françois sauvadet
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
est le président du département de la
côte d'or et vous présider cette
assemblée des départements de france on
va bien sûr longuement parlé de ce
congrès avec vous mais d'abord un mot de
la présidentielle on est en plein
congrès des républicains connaître
aujourd'hui les deux finalistes de ce
congrès ce que comme jean christophe
lagarde vous conditionner votre soutien
en fonction du candidat qui sera choisi
par les militants samedi ou est-ce que
vous soutiendrez ce candidat que quel
qu'il soit attendait d'abord ont
effectivement je suis issu du groupe de
droite centre indépendant des
départements de france mais j'oublie
posé que je suis président de cette adf
qui est une association pluraliste donc
j'ai pas l'intention de rentrer dans le
débat de la présidentielle
je me prononcerai personnellement mais
pas en tant que président évidemment
d'une association pluraliste bon mais
personnel l'a bien débat qui est engagée
par les républicains on sait très bien
d'ailleurs tout le monde sait que pour
proposer une alternative les seuls
républicains ne pourront pas à
l'emporter il faut un large
rassemblement une alliance naturelle
d'ailleurs depuis des années entre les
l'air lui dei sur impact clair moi la
seule ligne vraiment que j'ai rappelé
d'ailleurs de manière constante dans
toute ma vie politique c'est que je ne
souhaite pas la moindre pause it et avec
des idées qui relève de l'extrême droite
et donc ce bornage là pour moi il est
essentiel et ensuite effectivement il
n'est pas clair chez tous les candidats
des républicains pour vous écouter les
débats l'a vu quand même que certains se
sont rapprochés même s'y trouve est
compatible avec ces stèles idées portées
par mme par monsieur et mopar par
l'extrême droite pas franchement un
sacre il faut penser avec ce tir vous
avez entendu comme moi dans le débat je
veux pas personnaliser mais vous
attendent une certaine porosité dans les
idées donc pour moi c'est une ligne
rouge infranchissable dont clairement
c'est eric ciotti est choisi par les
militants les républicains samedi vous
ne lui apporterait pas votre soutien je
ne la porterai pas mon soutien en tout
cas pas s'il reste sur les mêmes
positions politiques naturellement
avec je le répète une porosité avec des
idées portées par monsieur zemmour et
cette thèse du grand remplacement enfin
dans le contexte qu'on traverse je crois
que nous avons besoin d'unité nationale
se retrouver sur des vraies valeurs et
d'apporter des réponses aux
préoccupations des français et les
quatre autres voulaient se tiendrait
quel que soit celui de jeu d'abord
attendre le résultat je vous en parlerai
après mais vous connaissez dallas le
sens de mon engagement l'attachement que
je porte aussi à une idée européenne
rénové l'attachement que je pense que
valeurs de la république au respect de
l'autre et en montant à la
décentralisation naturellement un
dernier mot là dessus puisque vous dites
vous parler de cette alliance de la
droite et du centre qui est perdure
depuis des années est ce que ce congrès
les républicains il a mis à mal cette
alliance est est ce que lui dit à
d'autres choix de se rallier au candidat
moi je pense d'abord vous savez que
d'abord il faut voir qui va sortir de ce
choix c'est une méthode qui a été choisi
par par le parti lui-même je n'en suis
pas membre vous le savez ce sont des
décisions qui lui appartiennent à un
exercice démocratique qui s'est fait
devant tous les français bon voilà
maintenant j'attends le résultat ce sera
le vote des républicains des des
adhérents du parti républicain qui dit
kylie qui déterminera bon voilà c'est
leur choix je le constate comme vous on
va parler de la crise sanitaire françois
sauvadet près de cinquante mille
nouveaux cas ont été recensés hier dans
le pays le gouvernement qui annonce des
tests pour les voyageurs de pays hors
union européenne est-ce suffisant est ce
que pour vous il faut aller plus loin
est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à
envisager la fermeture de nos frontières
d'abord sur la méthode mon jeu j'ai
apprécié que le premier ministre juste
avant de prendre les dernières mesures
face à l'évolution de la pandémie
consulte l'ensemble des présidents de
des grandes associations maires de
france régions de france et évidemment
les partenaires de france donc moi je
soutient des initiatives qui ont été
prises et vous avez dit mais ce qui vous
a écouté ah oui j'ai le sentiment qu'on
était écouté d'ailleurs sur le maintien
au thon comme le peut des classes c'est
ce que nous avions réclamées
un sur le contrôle des jeunes en tout
cas sur la vaccination des jeunes on
allait la demander des précisions
fournies étaient et entendu sur
l'essentiel et moi je pense que si un
seul message à faire passer aujourd'hui
à tous les français c'est que c'est vrai
nous avons à risque d'une cinquième
vague qu'il faut respecter les gestes
barrière se protéger et surtout se faire
vacciner moi je me suis réjoui que le
gouvernement prenne la décision de la
troisième dose pour tous les deux ce qui
ont plus de 18 ans moi même d'ailleurs
je me suis fait vacciner dès que j'ai pu
pour cette troisième d'autres donc vous
avez devant vous un président vacciner
trois fois justement puisqu'on parle de
cette vaccination l'allemagne va
débattre de cette vaccination
obligatoire au parlement d'ici la fin de
l'année où cela van der leyen dit
qu'elle est favorable à cette discussion
au niveau de l'union européenne est ce
que le gouvernement français doit ouvrir
cette discussion sera l'axé nation
obligatoire écoutez toutes les mesures
qui ont été prises conduisent assure
vaccinés ou j'ai comprise le délai
réduit pour la validité du pass en cas
de contrôle lorsqu'on n'est pas vacciné
sur une vaccination obligatoire qui ne
dit pas son nom bah oui mais si je
trouve ça très bien il ya la liberté
individuelle mais en même temps moi je
respecte toujours les libertés
individuelles mais dès lors qu'elle
remette en cause leur santé et surtout
la santé d'autrui il faut prendre des
mesures certes coercitives et je ne sais
pas si je ne pense pas qu'il fallait
jusqu'à la vaccination obligatoire mais
tout doit être mis en oeuvre pour que
les personnes se vaccine on sait très
bien que malgré les artistes itude qui
peut y avoir la vaccination c'est la
meilleure prévention pour éviter les
risques graves il ya sept points elle va
l'imposer par la rendre obligatoire
non je ne suis pas favorable à la rendre
obligatoire mais à prendre toutes les
mesures coercitives pour conduire les
personnes à prendre cette décision
puisqu'on parle de vaccination une
quinzaine de présidents de départements
socialistes ont écrit il y a quelques
semaines au premier ministre pour leur
dire qu'ils ne voulaient pas verser le
rsa aux personnes qui sont suspendus
justement parce qu'elles ne sont pas
vaccinés vous avez compris cette
démarche vous êtes d'accord avec eux
écoutez il ya eu un débat plus large et
à dire que on nous a demandé à nous
de verser le rsa à ceux dont le salaire
était suspendu franchement ça pose une
question de confiance enfin est-ce que
le rsa ça sert à ça est ce que le rsa
c'est la réassurance de ceux qui n'ont
pas voulu de vacciner donc le
gouvernement a décidé la
de leurs revenus tant qu'ils ne le
seront pas pour ce qui me concerne je ne
verserai pas le rsa à des personnes qui
ont refusé de se vacciner qu'elle assume
la responsabilité tout cas leur et ça
c'est pas fait pour être une réassurance
le rsa c'est un chemin qui est fait pour
les gens qui perdent leur emploi qui
sont en situation de grande fragilité et
que nous devons accompagner sur un
chemin de vie pour leur permettre de
retrouver la dignité l'emploi s'accélère
moi je ne verserai pas assurément et
ailleurs des conciliabules services
olivier ferrand une part de solidarité
nationale lui vous n'entendez pas cet
argument mais attendez la vraie
solidarité nationale c'est le saut
vacciner
est-ce que les départements sont prêts à
affronter cette cinquième vague ah oui
nous avons d'ailleurs savez on a
beaucoup parlé encore récemment du
couple maires préfets mais on a peu
parlé du couple med mère département et
de l'action des départements songez que
pendant toute cette période de pandémie
compris pendant le confinement tous nos
agents étaient sur le pont no 340 mille
agents étaient sur le pont nous allons
continuer de protéger les enfants malgré
le confinement nous avons continué
d'agir pour les personnes âgées nous
étions côté de ceux qui sont les plus
précaires nous avons accompagné
également l'aide alimentaire que nous
avons aussi apporté à ce qui est en
situation difficile nos jeunes étudiants
que nous avons aidé on était sur le pont
les campagnes de vaccination que nous
avons conduite moi je alors je regrette
vraiment que dans tous les discussions
qu'on a eues sur les tirer les bilans de
la crise on est pas parler de ce rôle du
département qui était majeur dans la
république pour ce lien social garantir
le lien social et la proximité été les
oubliés seul était notaire pour vous
amener pas été on était les premiers aux
premières lignes y compris pour la
campagne de vaccination de fond si tout
le monde annonce est acheté des masques
puis un seul coup tout le monde se
regardait pour savoir comment les
distribuer et là on s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait une grande chance de notre
pays ce sont les départements ceux
d'ailleurs le thème de ces assises oui
les départements sont qu une grande
chance pour la france mais ce que le
bill de cette crise sanitaire il a été
tiré selon vous pour les départements où
est ce que vous demandez plus de
compétences en matière de santé écoutez
nous nous souhaitons d'abord qu'il ya un
dialogue beaucoup plus nourris regardez
encore aujourd'hui j'ai eu des
témoignages d'un président de
département qui me faisait observer
qu'il ne recevait pas les informations
sur l'évolution de la pandémie il ya eu
pendant cette période une forme
d'arrogance sanitaire de la part des ars
donc moi ce que je demande c'est arrangé
pas vous les avoués ça s'est arrangé ça
s'est arrangé on est sorti d'une période
mais enfin on n'est pas encore au bout
du chemin moi je souhaite d'ailleurs que
l'on réinvente de nouveaux chefs de file
à pour qu'on soit en capacité d'agir
dans nos dans nos départements moi je
vous entendez dire tout à leur rappeler
ce que disait le présent à un public sur
les cendres de politique sociale enfin
j'étais très étonné franchement
on va traiter de la même manière la
protection de l'enfance ou d'insertion
où le vieillissement de la population en
seine saint denis dans la creuse ou en
montagne évidemment qu'il ya ceux des
politiques sociales et moi ce que je dis
au gouvernement c'est que la première
des inégalités c'est pas la façon dont
nous exerçons je vais terminer la
première égalité c'est pas la façon dont
nous exerçons la politique sociale nous
l'adaptons réalités territoriales et la
situation sociale est la première des
inégalités c'est qu'il ya des
départements qui n'ont pas les
ressources suffisantes pour faire face
aux missions aux évolutions sociétales
notamment au vieillissement de la
population et à la montée du rsa et on
va y venir et on va l'écouter le chef de
l'état justement vous parlez de cette
phrase on va l'entendre dans quelques
instants mais d'abord pour finir sur
cette crise sanitaire il ya une
aggravation de la crise dans le pays la
cinquième vague est là est-ce que du
coup vous avez hésité à tenir ce congrès
qui rassemble des centaines de personnes
bah écoutez nous allons avoir d'abord ce
congrès je vais vous le souhaiter que ce
soit des assises c'est à dire qu'on
puisse ensemble dire au gouvernement et
dire plus encore au candidat à la
présidence de la république ce que nous
voulons comment nous pensons qu'on peut
mieux agir pour les français on est une
crise de confiance vous l'avez vu même
pour les élections locales il ya eu
l'impact de la pandémie assurément mais
il ya moins de votants qui viennent
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment que quoi
qu'ils votent ça ne change rien nous
voulons mieux agir pour les français on
a une expertise on est les plus proches
du avec les maires nous allons dire aux
candidats ce que nous voulons mais on va
parler tous à françois sauvadet mais
justesse que vous avez hésité à tenir
chaud congrès pour aller plus loin les
présidents de départements de gauche ne
viendront pas parce qu'ils disent que ce
n'est pas possible de tenir ce congrès
en pleine crise sanitaire qu'est ce
qu'il s'est passé exactement dix ans
maintenant des taux dès fois de sérieux
on me dit on dit on vient pas et en même
temps le président du groupe sera là
demain pour participer au débat d'hier
soir il y avait des présidents
socialistes qui étaient là qui ont
participé aux débats il ya une
interrogation qui est exprimé par un
certain nombre d'élus y compris du droit
de centre indépendant du groupe de
nicolas lacroix évidemment que cette
interrogation légitime il vous est
demandé le report du congrès quelques
élus de gauche pas tout le groupe de
gauche d'ailleurs ont demandé le report
des assises je n'ai pas souhaité nous
respectons scrupuleusement les règles
qui nous sont imposés rien n'interdit à
ce jour les rassemblements tous nous
oblige à respecter les règles donc et
nous les respectons scrupuleusement
passe sanitaire port du masque
obligatoire dans tout dans tout le temps
tout le dans toutes ces assises nous
allons respecter évidemment
toutes les règles sanitaires qui nous
sont imposés on l'a vu il ya du gel
partout etc voilà on va va pas
s'interdire de vivre ce qu'il faut c'est
tenir compte du risque pandémique
nous sommes des élus responsables
plus de mille personnes seront là je
m'en réjouis ce qui montre bien
l'implication des conseillers à deux
conseillers départementaux de france a
adressé un message fort en disant si on
veut restaurer la confiance avec le
peuple fait confiance aux élus locaux on
a besoin de l'état mais je rappelle au
président de la république qu'il a
besoin aussi des 500000 locaux neige pas
je n'ai pas besoin de le rappeler
d'ailleurs aka crise du gilet jaune que
nous avons traversée jean castex sera là
et bien là
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas su une
période extrêmement difficile avec
edouard philippe qui était vraiment
alors là quand on le présente
aujourd'hui comme étant
décentralisateur et c'était à moi je
veux bien mais en tout cas c'est quand
même l'homme qui supprime la taxe
d'habitation 15 à supprimer le foncier
bâti pour les départements donc plus
d'autonomie fiscale
c'était le contrat de cartes à dire non
seulement n'a plus d'autonomie fiscale
mais on avait un contingentement nos
dépenses les 84
pour vous ça se passe mais avec jean
castex
restore il leur resterait un dialogue
d'abord parce que je pense que il a une
expérience d'élu local edouard philippe
il a été battu par philipp péter le
maire d'une grande ville voilà il est
pas lui le quel point j'étais élu local
mais steve maire d'une grande ville et
moi j'observe que j'observe que le
premier ministre actuel a été conseiller
départemental et connaît bien les
départements il a été lui-même
conseiller départemental je le rappelle
donc évidemment que le dialogue était
plus fluide bon donc il a essayé aussi
ils essayent de lever les irritants
notamment de la loisne autres et pas de
l'oie noter l'autre 3ds pardon ils
essayent de lever les irritants bon on
dialogue moi je suis sur une île qu'on
nous sommes fixés fermeté sur les
principes il faut qu'on change le cadre
on peut pas continuer comme ça avec des
décisions prises d'en haut qui s'impose
qui s'impose à nous sans nous redonner
la liberté d'adapter l'action publique
aux réalités territoriales et dialogue
donc c'est pour faire avancer tous les
dossiers que nous pouvons faire avancer
avec ce gouvernement dont voilà dont les
présidents dont le la face profil
puisqu'il va y avoir les élections
présidentielles d'année prochaine ouais
on va parler de ces dossiers un mot
juste effectivement vous avez intitulé
ce congrès à 6d lentement assises
nationales département qu'est ce que ça
change pourquoi pourquoi ce changement
de nom vous avec un renouveau en prenant
la tête de l'assemblée de départ c'est
pas marqué un renouveau d'abord j'ai
souhaité que tous les départements de
france qui a les lotions de que de la
façon dont ils ont vécu cette crise la
façon dont ils ont pu y répondre les
limites et les difficultés qu'ils ont
rencontrées et puis on a souhaité aller
au delà c'est à dire que dans le débat
présidentiel
moi j'attends pas de tout du candidat à
la présidentielle ce que j'attends de
lui c'est qu'il entende aussi ce que le
peuple a à dire est ce que les élus
locaux à lui dire donc on a engagé on
est là face à de profondes mutations
nous disons si vous voulez mieux agir
pour les français voilà la proposition
qu'on va vous faire donc tous les
départements est appelée à y travailler
102 proposition évidemment
symboliquement comme les 102
départements de france et ultra marins
d'ailleurs je salue notre collègue de la
réunion qui est arrivé hier soir
j'adresse un message de soutien à la
martinique la guadeloupe saint bat saint
barth et saint martin qui traverse une
période très difficile tout cas on passe
beaucoup une crise sociale majeure vient
aussi à la pandémie donc voilà on va
faire nos propositions pour dire voilà
le chemin qu'on propose aussi pour la
france pour mieux fonctionner mieux agir
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous de jean
castex demain ça s'est pas très bien
passé au congrès des régions de france
les présidents de région était très en
colère à la fin de leur congrès vous
vous redoutez la même chose où vous êtes
angérien je souhaite que on avance nous
avons quelques points sur la loi 3ds
comme on l'appelle donc il n'est pas le
nom ni la loi de décentralisation qui
n'était pas qui n'est pas la loi que qui
va qui va améliorer le cadre mais qui va
régler quelques problèmes techniques
bon il ya des sujets qui étaient pour
nous des irritants on a la compétence
route on exploite tout 375 mille
kilomètres de route qu'on entretient on
a des ingénieurs on a on sait faire
l'entretien des routes ont garanti la
sécurité sur nos itinéraires il ya neuf
lits km de routes transférés par le par
l'état qui le souhaitent plus les
entretenir qui les entretient d'ailleurs
pas suffisamment dans les conditions de
ce transfert créer un nouveau service
régional en transférant les routes
nationales aux régions enfin franchement
ça va être un échelon de complexité
supplémentaire donc tous nous disons
prioritairement laissez-nous assumer ce
que nous savons déjà faire et c'est tout
ce temps ailleurs ce qu'on demande dans
les landes nouveau décentralisation
laissez-nous agir ayons dans les
compétences qui nous sont déjà alloués
dans le social laissez nous respirer
laissez nous adapter les politiques aux
réalités territoriales laissez-nous agir
que l'état à impulser contrôle c'est son
rôle mais l'état l'état doit être garant
il ne peut pas le gérant de tous mais
sur cette loi 3ds elle sera examinée par
les députés la semaine prochaine elle a
déjà été examiné par le sénat qui l'a
beaucoup retravaillé est ce que vous
redoutez que les députés détricote
lettre avait passé le tricoter le
travail du cdas a déjà commencé en
commission vous l'avez constaté en
commission
on l'a on l'a vu et plusieurs
dispositions qui a été d'ailleurs
légitime qui avait été proposé par le
sénat je remercie le travail de gérard
larcher sur ce point nous avons
effectivement constaté ça mais ce que je
souhaite c'est que les engagements pris
soient tenus vous en avait parlé avec le
gouvernement
j'en ai parlé plusieurs fois avec le
premier ministre nous avons rencontré
jacqueline gourault à diverses reprises
mon prédécesseur également sa travail
qu'est qui date depuis déjà plusieurs
mois là dessus il vous a écouté le
gouvernement oui ça avance pas autant
qu'on le souhaiterait mais je souhaite
qu'en effet on aille au delà vous
parliez tout à l'heure des gestionnaires
de collège c'est invraisemblable on
confie dans ces collèges on s'occupe de
la restauration scolaire nous avons
aucune prise sur les gestionnaires qui
assure la gestion il ya de la cohérence
à redonner à l'action publique et
puisqu'on parlait de décentralisation
vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué tout à
l'heure mais on va écouter ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron lors du discours de
clôture devant les maires de france il a
parlé de décentralisation avec cette
phrase qui concernaient les départements
nous avons dans notre pays je crois fait
dernières années ces dernières décennies
trop souvent confondue la
décentralisation avec la délégation de
compétence
et ce n'est pas la même chose lorsqu'on
confie le rsa à des départements et
qu'ils n'ont aucune possibilité
de décider des règles de vraiment faire
la politique mais qui ne sont que des
payeurs aveugles
c'est pas de la décentralisation bilan
des courses les départements les plus
pauvres font quoi ils demandent de
recentraliser quand ils sont en
difficulté ce qu'on connaît en ce moment
dans certains territoires ultramarins en
seine-saint-denis
c'est une réalité et j'entends c'est ce
qu'ils appellent à la décentralisation
mais ayons eu débat est ce que dans
notre pays on vote pour avoir sans
politique sociale
non
comment vous avez réagi à cette phrase
moi j'étais très très surpris moi
d'abord j'ai d'autres la phrase ouvrons
le débat il ya un vrai débat quand on
quand on pense que le rsa c'est
simplement une distri sion dette sociale
sans mesure et qu'au moment où on verse
le rsa on engage la personne sur une
stratégie de devoir celui qui en perdent
d'addiction eh bien on les aide à se
sortir de cette situation celui qui est
loin de l'emploi on l'accompagnent sur
son chemin le rsa c'est pas simplement
un droit de se débarrasser du problème
c'est pas ça le rsa c'est un
accompagnement de la personne et donc
résumé une prestation de cette nature a
simplement la versement de l'aide jeu
pour moi j'invite le président à venir à
venir en côte d'or que je vais lui
montrer le travail que nous faisons au
quotidien pour accompagner les personnes
n'avaient dire qu'il ne veut pas dire
qu'il ne comprend pas de la nhra
inégalités mais je lui dis simplement
que la vraie inégalité
c'est précisément de laisser des
départements qui ont très peu de
ressources face une évolution de la
dépense du rsa en période de crise avec
des tendances à la baisse d'aidés des
ressources et avec un effet ciseau qui
fait qu'ils sont plus en dur quand on
demande à l'état de reprendre certains
départements le rsa c'est pas parce
qu'on ne sait pas faire c'est parce
qu'on se trouve dans des impasses un
certain nombre de nos collègues et même
en situation aujourd'hui où les droits
de nos terres comme vous appelez ont crû
beaucoup de départements restent en
situation fragile et ses brochettes à la
question de la renationalisation du rsa
dlp et la signer ce conseil est
favorable à ce qu'on pense à ceux
l'instant encore nationalisant les
politiques on va les rendre plus
efficaces enfin franchement quand
j'entendais tout le débat sur la
protection de l'enfance est ce que vous
croyez que le retour aux tasses de 2,2
par le passé c'est la bonne réponse
sélection nation c'est la direction de
l'action sociale vous en souvenez parce
que c'est la bonne réponse est-ce qu'on
va redonner toutes les routes à
l'état-major
seine saint denis a fait une erreur en
renonçant le rsa ou non j'ai l'air je le
comprends je ne le partage pas la très
large majorité ne souhaite pas le retour
la renationalisation du à ça parce qu'il
ya un problème de fond quand vous
distinguer le versement d'une prestation
du chemin pour en sortir
quel est le levier que vous avez notre
part il nous arrive aussi de supprimer
le reste pour ceux qui ne respectent pas
leurs devoirs ne peut pas y avoir de
droit sans qu'il y ait parallèlement des
devoirs qui est en capacité de le faire
c'est ça l'esprit de la décentralisation
donc j'ai dit au président de la
république ne confondons pas
déconcentration et décentralisation
moi je suis à partisans de la
décentralisation et du bon échelon pour
agir et du bonnet sont adaptés pour agir
en tenant compte des réalités
territoriales voilà l'enjeu ce sera un
débat de politique et l'aja désaccord
profond avec le président de la
république puisse compare les politiques
sociales à un mot sur les questions
d'autonomie de dépendance qui là aussi
sont à la charge des départements en
partie le gouvernement avait promis une
grande loi de dépendance qui n'a pas vu
le jour durant ce quinquennat il ya 400
millions d'euros qu'eurent été mis sur
la table ces dernières semaines est ce
que pour vous c'est suffisant comment
vous qualifier ce quinquennat sur ce
sujet et non ce n'est pas suffisant bon
on n'est pas allé au bout de la démarche
il ya eu le débat cela cinquième branche
bon il faut absolument qu'on soit au
rendez-vous du vieillissement de la
population alors qui se traduit de
manière d'abord il ya une ambition du
maintien à domicile c'est tout le débat
qu'on a lues sur le tarif horaire là
aussi j'aurais préféré que il ya un
dialogue qui construit avec le
gouvernement avant de fixer un tarif à
22 euros fixé d'en haut alors qu'on sait
très bien que dans le monde rural là où
il faut passer du temps dans sa voiture
pour aller assurer une personne âgée de
son de l'environnement
juste et précis pour les
donc évidemment que la faute des tarifs
différenciés bon enfin au département
s'y sont engagés mais fois l'au delà on
efface un défi du vieillissement les
ehpad
accueille maintenant des personnes de
plus en plus âgés âge moyen dans mon
département d'accueil dans les ehpad ses
82 83 84 ans avec des séjours plus
courtes et des niveaux d'autonomie et
d'indépendance
extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué donc tous ces
sujets là sont devant nous le
vieillissement de la population c'est
une chance individuelle mais ça doit
devenir aussi un enjeu collectif et là
nous avons besoin aussi de la solidarité
nationale jeudi au chef de l'état
laissez-nous agir contrôle et impulser
mais assuré aussi de l'équité du de
l'accompagnement financier des
départements pour pouvoir assurer leurs
missions n'attendez pas qu'il vous
demande de reprendre sans charge parce
que on arrive à mieux r en proximité que
de tout décider depuis paris ça c'est
une conviction profonde que j'ai pour
avoir exercé à la fois des fonctions
parlementaires pendant 25 ans et
pourrait être élu local je trouve que il
faut que ce débat ait lieu je remercie
le président de la république de l'avoir
lancée parce que les départements de
france sont très engagées pour apporter
des réponses sans doute pas les mêmes
mais j'espère un chemin de convergence
et ce sera peut-être un débat de la
présidentielle comment les départements
temps de peser dans cette présidentielle
ah bah non on va voir notion de
proposition vous allez voir le débat on
a devant nous d'aider des enjeux de
transformation sociétaux de temps
sociétal majeur
regardez vous à l'écouté vous allez
envoyer
changement climatique les effets de la
crise même sur le on parle aujourd'hui
d'un exode urbain vous imaginez la
relation travail a changé l'arrivée du
télétravail le digital le service public
est en train de changer imaginez que va
être le services publics dématérialisés
ce qui va se déshumaniser nous avons des
réponses à apporter en proximité donc
nous allons faire des propositions pour
agir mieux pour les français que vous
demandez vous aux candidats et faire des
propositions que vous allez entendre
candidat est ce que vous allez leur
demander bien sûr les choses je souhaite
d'ailleurs qu'on travaille avec région
de francs va le faire nous on le
proposera évidemment ce nouveau chemin
pour la france pour mieux agir on le
proposera à tous les candidats à la
présidentielle j'espère que nous serons
entendus nous sommes aussi la france le
chef de dial l'état ben évidemment il a
un rôle singulier dans la république
française surtout la vème république
mais nous sommes aussi la france et nous
avons joué envie de jouer pleinement
notre rôle pas simplement dénonçant vous
parliez moi je ne me sens pas dans
l'opposition je veux que les
départements de france jouent pleinement
leur rôle de proposition et d'opposition
si on ne nous entend pas nous écoute pas
parce que les français attendent de nous
qu'on soit aussi à leur écoute et qu'on
réponde à leurs difficultés un dernier
mot sur territoire signé puisque vous le
dites vous allez faire ses propositions
vous allez en temps entendre on imagine
les candidats avec les maires de france
avec régions de france
qui ont sont rassemblés sous la bannière
territoire unis est ce que vous êtes
encore si unie que ça aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est compliqué entre
les départements et les régions de l'est
des états unis ça s'est créé j ai
participé à la création je remercie
gérard larcher je remercie tous les
présidents de région de et de aider des
merdes d'y avoir participé c'était pour
dire cela peut pas continuer comme ça à
prendre les élus locaux comme étant des
sous traitants de l'état ne sont pas des
sous traitants nous sommes des élus du
peuple exerçant des responsabilités et
dans un dialogue construit avec l'état
pour participer à une république
décentralisée qui est
constitutionnellement reconnus comme
tels qui est politiquement encore en
construction donc voilà non c'est
compliqué avec les régions non c'est pas
compliqué moi je suis à la région de
france nous avons des débats avec
régions de france nous avons des débats
sur l'économie nous souhaitons reprendre
une compétence en économie de proximité
pas s'il ya des trous dans la raquette
les régions ne veulent pas nous voulons
améliorer nos relations dans un certain
nombre de domaines on voit la difficulté
nous avons les cartes scolaires n'ont
pas le transport scolaire on voit
combien c'est complexe à gérer au
quotidien donc il ya des plages de
discussions jeudi on va pas rester
simplement unis pour être en contre ou
en opposition et de dire ce qui ne va
pas je leur ai proposé à carole delga et
à à monsieur destin au président lee
star devrait proposer un nouveau chemin
j'aurais dit travaillons ensemble à
dégager ce que nous voulons pour la
france pour les cinq prochaines années
donc on a commencé ce travail c'est
compliqué mais en même temps c'est la
seule chance d'éviter que le tout
gouvernement quel que soit le prochain
gouvernement puisse se jouer de chacun
d'entre nous en fonction de l'allégeance
pour nous dire ces régions ces
départements ces mères nous avons
évidemment à chemin à construire
ensemble pour être utile moi c'est ça
mon obsession qu'on soit utile aux
français qui en ont marre d'avoir les
champs de complexité devant lesquels ils
sont placés et nous-mêmes canovas et des
chants de complexité nous en paix avec
une sorte d' empêchement d'agir nous
voulons retrouver la capacité à agir
mieux merci beaucoup merci françois
sauvadet d'avoir été à notre invité ce
matin on suivra bien évidemment sur
public sénat vos travaux et ce congrès
des départements de français
[Musique]